everyone thanks thanks for coming in
these are members of the house senate
democrat republican who uh
all have an extremely keen interest in
doing what uh what i said once before
that i'd
love to be the president of preside over
the end of cancer as we know it
these are the folks in the house and
senate
who'd love to preside over cancer the
end of cancer as we know it
they all were critical in the cares act
which put about nine billion dollars
into nih to
deal with cancer and cancer research and
uh
the vice president i are of the view
that we can make significant strides
in fighting cancer and alzheimer's and
other diseases
if we take a slightly different approach
and
what i want to talk to them about today
is
how we go about uh taking advantage of
the
work they've done to get us where we are
today
because i think we're on the cusp of
some real breakthroughs across the board
on cancer and uh that's what we're gonna
talk about
and probably to all of you like all of
us
cancer is personal for almost everybody
it's probably the one word that is the
most frightening word in english
language to people
when they hear that c word cancer it's
uh
it is it is just devastating and
i always ask that when i talk about
cancer i'd
ask the audience if they to raise their
hand if any of them were suffering from
cancer as i spoke i know they lost
someone and virtually
70 of every audience whether or not it's
4
000 people or 400 people and a lot of
folks in this
room have like many of you like maybe
have been victims of cancer and overcome
it but there's so much hope
that that's what i want to talk about
with these folks about
what we do from a legislative and
substance point of view to make the kind
of inroads i think we can make